[Music]
welcome to a fresh take on the news
putting you at the center of the
national conversation
about the issues that matter to you most
tonight war continues to rage in europe
as russia bombards ukraine
more than a million people have fled the
country civilians are under fire
and there are international calls for
china to intervene
i'm trevor phillips and this is the
great debate
[Music]
[Applause]
each week we go to the heart of the
issue dominating the headlines
tonight as we continue the conversation
about russia's invasion of ukraine our
viewers panel from across the country
and across the world will have their say
they'll tell their stories and they'll
hold our studio panel to account joining
us this week
bill browder businessman head of the
global magnitsky justice campaign
co-founder of the institute for
strategic dialogue and expert in
disinformation sasha havlicek
the former foreign office minister
alastair burt
sophia gaston director of the british
follow foreign policy group
and joining us from westminster for the
first part of the show for returns to
commitment in the comments the
conservative mp and military veteran bob
seely
all here to answer the question
can the west stop vladimir putin
[Music]
there is fresh condemnation tonight
after vladimir putin's forces shelled a
nuclear power station the worrying signs
from president putin is in his words he
seems to indicate no limit
we have sanctioned
russian oligarchs and russian
organizations
these
sanctions that you can see here
equivalent of a war he has
underestimated the ukrainians he's
underestimated their leader and he has
underestimated the unity of the west
immediate introduction of no-fly zone
over ukraine is needed because only this
measure can guarantee that russia will
not hit nuclear infrastructure with
rockets and air bombs
[Music]
in order to bring a no-fly zone in it
would need to be enforced and that would
almost inevitably mean that we would be
engaged directly with russian aircraft
[Music]
we're starting as always with our
viewers panel let's go to the wall and
talk to elaine hamilton and sunderland
elaine
speak to us
how long do you think the sanctions will
take
to have any serious effect
on putin's war
thank you elaine very direct question
there which i'll
first start with you bob seely elaine's
question is
how long will sanctions take to have any
serious effect on vladimir putin's wall
bob seeley what do you think
good evening good evening to your
viewers i think elaine's question is a
very good one and the simple answer is
we don't know
vladimir putin has prepared for this war
for some time because he's built up a
war chest of over 600 billion dollars
quite a lot now which he can't access so
that's a potential uh you know
potentially important he has made a
great claim in the past of russia being
a sovereign nation and what he means by
that is russia being very
self-sufficient he claims that russia is
one of the few truly sovereign nations
on earth
and i think that now is going to be
tested i think these sanctions will
begin to have an effect very quickly
whether it will have enough of effect to
um uh to dissuade him of this course of
action is another matter entirely and
that might be a much much longer process
if you had to bet bob silly
do you think that uh the sanctions as
effective as they may be in the medium
and long term
will
deter him from
his war aim of uh controlling or
subjugating i should say ukraine
uh okay trevor really good again i think
it is more likely than not i'm going to
put a negative view because putin a
thinks that the russians can endure more
than most people i.e he will make them
endure more
that the first point
and secondly he is willing to pay an
extraordinarily high price for getting
ukraine back uh up to threatening
nuclear war and we don't know if he
would ever go through with those threats
but this for him is what people call an
existential issue so it's a matter of
life and death and i think the the
russian
security elite and you're talking about
a very small number of people whose
opinions may well not be shared by the
massive population in russia that's a
very important thing to say that
security elite has got itself into
position over the last few years of near
hysteria let's pick up that point about
the soul of russia
um
i want to bring in anton from our
viewers panel anton is one of a number
of russians living in the uk that we'll
be hearing from over the course of the
next hour and i just want to make clear
that understandably they've asked us not
to
use their surnames
anton
what do you make of this what is your
view about what he'll do
well first of all obviously it's it's
terrific what's happening um and it's
absolutely unexpected i think 10 days
ago
many of russians would stand and say we
don't expect that actually go that far
but it actually did so it's um i have to
say it's it's a surprise to a lot of
people um in terms of sanctions
specifically so
i do agree that it will take some time
before the course of action may actually
change because that will directly depend
on how the
ordinary people
feel the results of those um
sanctions and if that gonna cause any
internal um
disagreement put it that way or even
maybe you know more protest or any any
of that action um i think today some
ordinary people have already experienced
um issues
because of sanctions i've spoken to
friends um in russia and yeah there is
impact over there
will that be enough to
cause a lot of steer i'm not sure it's
hard to say today all right anton stay
there for a moment um
sophia gastron
sanctions
do you think they're going to be able to
do enough fast enough
i mean it's quite clear that president
putin's not being motivated by economic
stability and he's quite clear to sell
his own people down the river
to pursue this
really astonishing act of evil
of course the question is really you
know whether or not these economic
sanctions
can actually move from a period of uh
you know
he will be very actively trying to
harness the sanctions as a tool of
cohesion in russia
the question is does it eventually get
to a point where it actually turns the
russian people against him and his
regime brother you've
worked for a long time with people
who oppose putin and you're
famously
one of those people
do you think that sanctions can work
fast enough to change his behavior to
save people in ukraine
well it all depends how you define
sanctions so we're we're not um we you
know sanctions is a broad term
uh we've started to sanction russia
we've frozen the
central bank reserves of russia
we have uh disconnected a number of
banks from swift uh we've sanctioned
some oligarchs but there's still a lot
more sanctioning that needs to be done
to say we have a complete sanctions
program so for example we've
disconnected 70 percent of the banks
from swift but there's another being the
international banking messaging system
exactly so basically if you if you
disconnect 100 of the banks from swift
then it pretty much knocks russia back
to the dark ages economically we've
sanctioned a dozen oligarchs we probably
need to sanction a hundred oligarchs
and in my mind this is not about
changing putin's mind he he doesn't he
doesn't have a reverse gear he doesn't
go in reverse all he does is go forward
all he does is escalate um there's no
negotiation and so in my mind the
purpose of sanctions is to basically
deplete him of the money to execute this
war
and the war is very expensive it's
costing them billions of dollars a day
maybe more than that and if he has no
access to his internal capital and if he
has no access to his foreign capital
through the oligarchs then at some point
as he's going forward he's going to
stall out from lack of money and that's
the whole hope of this thing but the
issue is time isn't it let's just go
back to our wall for the moment um i
want to talk to
sarmad samad sabir
i think ukraine will eventually will
fall because nato will not support
i think they should but they won't
the other problem is when the
cold war was finishing they agreed usa
and nato they agreed with russia not to
expand nato that was the biggest mistake
they had made
and
after that they agreed with
ukraine to include them in nato that was
an other mistake which they made
and then the third
mistake which they
they made they provided safe heavens
to the russian oligarchs
so when all of these things they add
together that is the mistake which west
and usa they made and that provided and
the that enabled russia to
attack okay thank you so much um
bob silly someone to bear says
he's not optimistic
he thinks ukraine's going to fall
i mean i'm not optimistic because it's
pretty depressing situation and clearly
deterrence has failed but i mean i half
agree with someone look that there were
no promises made over nato there may be
some verbal hints and nobody can you
know i wasn't i wasn't in the
negotiations but gorbachev himself said
there was no significant promises over
nato because nobody was thinking about
nato at the time so gorbachev has
confirmed that there weren't any
promises broken over nato what i do
think that somehow right on is that
actually we should have been wiser about
not offering nato membership to georgia
and ukraine because then that gave putin
the excuse to move he might well have
done so anyway
uh by um by splitting serbia and
recognizing the independence of kosovo
they have also repeated the russians
have also repeatedly referred to that so
again we've given them excuses for what
they may have done anyway but rather
than flirt with the idea of nato
membership what we should have said
tonight to ukraine is you're not going
to be a member of nato for 20 years but
what we will do is make you very
difficult to invade we should have made
ukraine too bitterest pill rather than
sort of flirting with the idea of nato
enraging putin enraging the kremlin and
giving him an excuse he might well have
moved anyway sasha havelichek
our fault
well this is the thing i think we have
made a number of mistakes but i don't
think those are the mistakes
um putin has repeatedly tested western
resolve
um to see how far he could go the next
time round
from the invasion of georgia to
crimea of course this war in ukraine
isn't actually new
to the war in syria where he perpetrated
war crimes that went entirely unanswered
by the international community those red
lines that have been crossed and crossed
again
we had opportunities
to push back
to start with sanctions earlier on that
would have degraded his capabilities to
get further and further and further we
had opportunities to start to really
have an impact on his propaganda
machinery domestically globally we
haven't done that until now we've only
just started to have um measures taken
in in that regard so we've made a lot of
mistakes and it isn't so un
unbelievable that putin would assume
that there would be very little pushback
from nato from
uh from the eu from the transatlantic
alliance because there hasn't been to
date so what i would say is um
we need to have the resolve now and i do
think that we're seeing some really
quite seismic changes in in response
we've seen the eu come to the table
offer uh weaponry in record time we've
seen a complete hundred and eighty
degree turn around in german foreign
policy they're investing in their
military yeah they're providing a
hundred billion i think huge 100 billion
and this is a massive departure in terms
of their own uh foreign policy uh since
the the end of the the war the second
world war we are starting we we see the
eu now offer ukraine membership of the
eu start to use enlargement as an actual
tool of influence again in the
neighborhood so there's there are some
seeds for hope if we can sustain it now
that's the other question well we'll
come to that alistair burt um this was
never your own specific territory but
you were in the foreign office for quite
a long time yeah
we may be doing the right thing now but
five years too late
and i think there's a lot of analysis
that can be done about what happened in
the past but there are some absolutes
here
um
whatever our review of policy might be
we've reached a situation where what is
being done is unconscionable and without
excuse
and we have to be very clear about that
i mean looking back on what was done um
i think there were moments when we might
have been clearer
i was involved in the discussion in
syria in 2013
when obama's red line was crossed with
the use of chemical weapons in syria and
i remember arguing with colleagues in
the house of commons about the impact of
the united kingdom
not being prepared to challenge that by
suggesting that there might be military
action to follow
and i remember talking directly to mps
and saying if you think a situation in
which a combination of assad iran and
russia is is successful if you think
that's in british interests i think
you're wrong and then parliament voted
against giving the government even the
options you didn't win we didn't win and
i think you can look back on a number of
things but
that would be we've got to be very
careful that that does not excuse what
is happening it's something there's an
old saying and bob is a soldier and i
never uh i never was but
you don't know what happens when the
first bullet is fired it is true that
russia must have prepared for this putin
must have prepared for this but some
things have happened that he didn't
expect i think the extraordinary
response of the ukrainian people is one
the coming together of the eu and others
is another all that and the protests so
i think this is different in character
from what he expected we'll come on
actually to
what happened next as it were and how we
think about it strategically but
i want to just stick with where we are
tonight and come back to see our wall
regular viewers will remember that last
week we spoke to
marina ivanyak
and marina
talked about the experience of people
she knew in
ukraine and also
called for the no-fly zone now marina um
what do you make of what's happened in
the last week how are you feeling
tonight
so every day ukraine and ukrainian needs
more and more help so me and my friend
we are trying in the coming days driving
to you try to drive to ukraine and
deliver 500 donated sleeping bags and
some humanitarian help as well and on
the way back i'm planning to take my
husband's parents to the united kingdom
so the world acted late to prevent
russian invasion marina um we know
you're going to go tomorrow
travel safely
thank you
uh bob seeley i know you have to get
back to business in the commons but
thank you so much for joining joining us
we're going to go
for a break now but this is the great
de-break up next who's telling the true
story of what's really happening in
ukraine
russian state communications regulator
says it has decided to completely block
access to facebook in the country russia
today rt's own editor-in-chief called
the network an information weapon
in russia protesters again took to the
streets across the country those who see
through the propaganda and know this war
is wrong it's unprecedented for the mod
to release intelligence via a post on
social media a sign of britain using
information to fight back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm inzamam rasheed and i'm sky's north
of england
correspondent we give a voice to
communities often unheard and unserved
from a region with a distinct history
and global impact
[Music]
[Music]
amnan koji
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the great debate
can the west stop vladimir putin
the images played around the world of
the ukraine invasion often show horribly
familiar scenes
men conscripted to fight
tanks rolling in and gunfire and
shelling hitting towns and cities
but this war is being fought on another
front too
the information battle is raging online
as both sides tell their own version of
events
clive esterman uh you're in accra i
think you're watching this
and you've got a view about the
information war clive yes
yes thank you very much um
i like the point that sasha raised
what about her dialogue my question is
who is controlling the propaganda about
the russian invasion and what is the
endgame
thank you clive
so clive's uh got a
straightforward question for our panel
who is controlling propaganda about the
russian invasion
and what is the end game
sasha what do you think
the russians have seen information as a
central pillar of their domestic and
foreign policy
for always and they've invested really
heavily in building out
an infrastructure for information
operations around the world that
combines
effective state media which is
essentially an extension of the
kremlin's
foreign policy arsenal
so rt putting it combines that with all
sorts a massive network of pro kremlin
influencers around the world and then
all the co the covert tactics that we
came to associate in 2016 with brexit
and the u.s presidential elections in
the west because this has been going on
of course in russia's fear of influence
for much much much longer but the bot
nets the cyborg nets the troll farms and
and of course all the hacking that we've
seen and that
that power um
you ask the end game the end game is
really to undermine
um
liberal the the liberal
world order and and the liberal
democracies that underpin it it is to
undermine the very concept of truth and
a shared reality and in the context of
this war it has laid the foundations
for a domestic audience and for a
russian audience in ukraine and
elsewhere domestic audience in russia in
russia for um for this conflict um
providing reasons for this conflict
telling the people that this is about
saving the people of ukraine from a nazi
regime um saving them saving russians
from
attack within the country
let me um let's go let's go to tanya
tanya you're in
hertfordshire
um
speak to us about your experience and
your family i think
hello yes i've been living in the uk for
20 years but my dad and my family is
still in russia in siberia
and um yes i am very sad about what's
happening in ukraine and i'm trying to
talk to my family but unfortunately back
in russia but unfortunately i do believe
television that you believe putin's
propaganda and
i actually had to pause my communication
with lots of my friends and family
because we just can't understand each
other they are they they genuinely
believe what they see on television they
genuinely believe that what russia is
doing in ukraine is not the war
but it's a special operation to free
ukrainians and especially believe that i
am brainwashed and everyone in in the
west
watching the news and also
brainwashed into thinking that
that's not right
so yes so when you say to them you see
it in a different way they just don't
believe you
they yes we start arguing with each
other and yes they try to persuade me
saying whatever i'm watching that's not
right that i've been in the uk to learn
and i i don't really see the real
picture and they know the real picture
they know all the stories
they tell me all the stories about what
happened in daniel's kendamas and about
uh they always say the same things what
you've been doing for eight years since
they were in donbass and their russian
children being killed by ukrainians and
the west so that's the main propaganda
which they believe in all right
stay there for a moment tanya let's talk
to
someone who is actually in ukraine
vitaly
uh i think you must have heard what
tanya's just been saying what do you
think
yeah so i totally agree
this is a huge problem how one can reach
russians who are in russia and tell them
bring them some alternative information
to what they receive from television
because television is russia is
controlled by the kremlin and people
have very few options to get information
from elsewhere so social networks are
one of such options and since the
beginning of the war ukrainians so
ukrainian media civil society
organizations but also western media
have been using social networks like
facebook twitter youtube to break
through to russians and to explain them
what's really going on that it's not
some kind of special military operation
that it's real war in which civilians
die but so
in my opinion that has proven to be
really effective since russia has
blocked facebook twitter uh it's talking
about blocking youtube and there are
even rumors about russia breaking off
from the internet completely and like
establishing its own internal network
which has been tested since 2019
so
in my opinion the only way now to reach
russians on internet is via telegram a
messenger which is fairly popular in
ukraine and in russia and maybe through
russian social networks vaca and anaklas
nikki but these are less popular thank
you vitali
bill browder this is um
pretty grim isn't it i mean
uh if
we're in a situation where russian
people literally can't see the world in
the way the rest of us do
what are the chances of any change
well it all depends on where change
comes from so we we've talked about
where the information war
is being won by the russians but let me
just talk for a second about where the
information war has been won by the west
in past conflicts
putin has created so many alternative
narratives so for example when when
georgia was invaded um putin said they
fired on us first and um wes said no
russia fired on georgia first and
everyone was all confused
with this with this conflict the united
states and great britain and all the
allies every day
for six weeks said russia is going to
invade russia is going to invade russia
can invade and by the time russia
invaded
we all had an agreement
in the west
that russia invaded that this was there
was no other example there was no other
explanation for this and because of that
we were able to all lock arms and then
create external consequences for the
russians and if we hadn't done that i
think that this this situation would be
far worse if there's any chance this is
going to end it's going to end because
of the economic dislocation of russia
from the west all right well there is
more than one russian view we may we'll
be hearing it in a moment
coming up we'll be joined by the russian
chess grand master and chairman of the
renewed democracy initiative
gary kasparov
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
can the west stop vladimir putin
that's a topic for this week's great
debate before we come back to our
viewers panel we're joined from new york
by the russian chess grand master and
human rights campaigner gary kasparov a
lot of people in europe are
hoping that in some way shape or form
mr putin can be deterred
do you think that is possible
yes it is possible
i would say it's not just possible it's
absolutely necessary vladimir putin
is an existential threat not to only to
ukraine or to europe but to to the world
and unless we defeat him in ukraine
so the consequences could be beyond our
ability to control
uh there is no doubt that putin will
continue testing nato uh for its resolve
to fight back
and he's in desperate situation the
russian economies is in terrible shape
and as every dictator after 22 years in
power he needs uh foreign aggression to
justify his um stay
on
on top of uh
russian power and um
i think that's what is missing is the
political will uh to recognize the
reality
there is no compromise with cancer
there's only one way it's a you need
you need a surgery and as long as putin
stays in kremlin there will be no peace
well how do you get him out there are
only
two ways i guess the russian people
themselves or a war
look we don't need a war uh uh a new war
because one war is already happening and
as we could see ukrainian army despite
the fact that they were
not well equipped uh uh and the free
world missed so many opportunities to
arm ukrainians to the keys and to
to even to rise the the cost of of this
um criminal war for putin that's still
inflicting huge damages to vladimir
putin but we need to combine things so
to overthrow dictator you need to add
few components one is the geopolitical
military defeat and with support of the
free world ukrainian army can do it
then blockade financial
economic and technological throw putin's
russia in the technological stone age
russian economy depends
on on western tech support almost
exclusively
and let's see what happens so whether
it's one week whether in one month it
will not take long before russian people
will start looking around looking at at
their freezers as we say russia
eventually frieza always beats tv
and and i think it's it will end up with
a massive revolt but we need real
sanctions we need political will to
finish putting off so far unfortunately
the free world is always looking for
some middle ground so this i don't feel
that there's the the the resolve and and
political strengths in america or in
europe to to fight this war as as as it
has to be fought it's not chess you
cannot have a tie it's either we win or
putin wins so briefly war in your view
is in war with nato is inevitable
look you know it's not about putin putin
can do can tell anything he wants and
he's crazy but let's let's all deal with
him it's about people who will carry his
orders and the moment these generals
recognize that they're dealing with
nader i want to see how
um what was what is their readiness to
sacrifice their own lives if they know
fly zone is imposed i wanted to see how
many kamikazes that are in the russian
air force that will continue their
murderous campaign of killing ukrainian
civilians gary kasparov thank you very
much indeed
let's go back to the wall and talk to
carl
mckeever
a lot of support there from what mr
cospara has been saying but gary uh
carl what uh what do you make of it
hi trevor well i'm a business consultant
and i work internationally i've
previously worked in moscow for both
harley-davidson and ikea two brands
which have recently said that they're
going to pause their operations there
now for me it was very evident that when
i was there people who'd been employed
directly by these brands were much more
liberal in their approach um and values
they were certainly less suspicious and
cynical and really much more open than
many of the other people that i met
now these are the very people modern
russians which are being shut down being
cancelled and arrested by putin's regime
so my question is how can the west seize
this moment to build trust with a new
generation of russians who will all need
for peace
thank you carl
there's a question for our panel um
how can the west rebuild trust with a
new generation
of russians alistair bert
whether is existing engagement
with russians
keep going
there may be academic researchers
lancaster university is just one of the
universities in the country that will
have russian students
who will be there
to make a mistake that all russians
think the same is obviously wrong but
equally as we have heard the stories
they are being told means that we
to be complacent that they think as we
do is obviously equally wrong
but i think there has to be a a
combination
this isolation of
the kremlin and the decisions taken by
putin must continue the people will
reflect that as gary gasparov was saying
the the freezer will be affected people
will know that something's happened
those who have uh stories coming back
from ukraine will know that the
narrative that they were fed that it was
the liberation of russians there is
untrue as they are met not with roses on
the tops of tanks but bullets and guns
and resistance gradually word will get
through you've got to believe that there
is an opportunity for that and every
step must be taken to isolate and
confront in every possible way in order
to prevent the catastrophic war that
people fear might be inevitable but i
think engaging with those whom we know
and there are plenty of us that have
contact with those in russia keep that
going so they know that people outside
are not as putin will tell them russia
phobes but want to work with people in
russia but be perhaps much more
clear-eyed than we've been in the past
about the desires of the state that
putin runs all right let's get a sense
of
quite how that
sentiment plays with people
in russia or people connected with
russia um
constantine and albino i think
you would have a view about this
yes most certainly yeah um i think it is
extremely important to continue speaking
to russian people of all the generations
yes younger russians like us we we're
completely against the war we woke up
with the feeling of shame uh 10 days ago
with a feeling of anger
against people who represent us in the
government um
and so it it's it's crucial that we find
a way to um
to represent our country now and other
russian people who speak against the war
um here and in other countries around
the world to be the real um embassy of
russian people
yes and i just wanted to say that
russian people they are against this war
it's just become extremely dangerous to
speak up and the people who come to the
protests in russia they are very brave
people
thank you let's um let's talk to another
russian viewer who is in london
liz
um what what is your view do you think
that
there is a generation or a second
russian population that can be persuaded
to look at this differently to the
kremlin
uh i agree that there is
a lot of people who um
who don't want this war who don't sign
up sign under this decision
and
it's incredibly hard to say how many
because it's very dangerous it's up to
15 years in prison to say anything
against the war there were 5 000 people
detained yesterday on protests
people are afraid to be drafted to the
army and fight the war they don't want
but they as as gary is saying they see
already that the freezer is impacted as
well so the prices go up people get
getting fired from their jobs
and
i know that putin is using sanctions as
a way to reinforce the west as an enemy
so it's it's probably not really
bringing more people on the streets now
uh it's just silencing more people
making them angry
for right now so those who are trying to
flee um they are fleeing to wherever
they can and it's not the west at the
moment it's turkey it's georgia because
that's where the flights exist
but
what's going to happen next it's hard to
say we are all kind of rid of our
identity at the moment okay liz thank
you so much
sophia um
how realistic is this hope
that there can be a sea change in
russian sentiment that would dislodge mr
putin
i mean i think it's really difficult as
uh many of our speakers have have made
clear tonight there are enormous
inhibiting factors against russians
being able to speak out anyone who's
involved in this protest if anyone who's
accessing information anyone who's
trying to sort of push the needle on
this is is facing severe grave personal
danger for themselves and their families
so we shouldn't make light of that i do
think that in the west we need to be
absolutely clear that this is an issue
with putin and his regime in the kremlin
and not with the russian people nor the
russian culture and i think we need to
think about
a longer-term plan here the you know the
the foreign secretary here has talked
about creating a network of liberty that
needs to go beyond governments that
needs to be about people as well and i
think we need to think about immigration
tools and pathway schemes people you
know who want to
find safe passage into the west for a
new life we need to think about our
higher education system ways we can
bring that talent over for people who
are seeking a new life and i mean we've
been doing this to great effect in hong
kong with a very generous scheme to
british nationals overseas there who are
who were you know facing persecution of
with china's crackdown um in in hong
kong we need to think about pathways for
russia because i think what is really
concerning here is that you know putin
is essentially creating a much more
isolated
state and that is dangerous for the
russian people but it's also dangerous
for us because the more disconnected and
dislocated we become from this regime
the less you know the more opacity there
is the harder it is to understand what's
going on that's when you have sort of
danger of miscommunication and things
that can really escalate
you mentioned china and in fact you want
to come to
that example and that the influence of
that country in a moment
you're watching the great debate
after the break does china hold the
diplomatic answer to the ukraine
invasion
[Applause]
i'm david blevins and i'm skye's senior
ireland correspondent
[Music]
it was everything that a journalist
might want in a story a story that you'd
be proud to have filmed
that they didn't want journalists to see
the real story
it was very tiring it was very sad it
was very scary at times there's no need
for this but you have to keep going
look at that
you don't want to
they push the protesters further back
here as around two or three hundred
still
remain i'm dan whitehead and i'm sky
news's west of england correspondent
[Music]
this fan goes on to the streets of
plymouth seven days a week 365 days a
year these facilities are at the moment
are a lifesaver solid problem
[Music]
from fishing communities to bustling
cities we spend every day reporting from
across the region hearing from people
who have real stories
i have nowhere to live for
about three or four months
there are still people inside the
properties here
they're coming from the epicentre of
what is now a global health pandemic
we were seeing and speaking to young
women who were selling themselves right
on the high street it was desperately
sad and the fact it was happening right
in the hearts of this community
before brexit these oysters were being
exported to the eu but the trade stopped
overnight
what's your feeling about the future
blake
i'd all be
finished i don't know
[Music]
[Applause]
i love my job because
i get to do something that is
contributing to a better future
[Music]
[Music]
this is the great debate
can the west stop vladimir putin
and if not the west
how about china
australian prime minister scott morrison
says no other country will have a bigger
impact in bringing the war to an end
but so far president xi jinping has held
back from condemning mr putin's actions
and over the weekend china suspended
coverage of premier league matches in
order to avoid broadcasting displays of
solidarity with ukraine
let's talk to michael moe in cambridge
michael
uh is an old friend of the program what
do you think
hi trevor um i have a tick on this
question i think but i think it would be
better to put it out first so my
question is
should the world expect china to be a
key negotiator for peace in ukraine
before i come to our panel what do you
think michael you you probably know the
chinese regime better than pretty much
any of us
um
i think it would be rather naive for the
west to believe that she's china could
be a negotiator out of goodwill um so
she is fishing with his third term
preparation so unless he could get a
good results or a positive impact
contributing to his third term success
i don't think that
she or china as a whole
uh would be helping out uh of the
situation
michael thank you sophie gaston
i think it's important to note that um
president xi has very different
compact with
his citizens in china
than president putin does he has a
compact that is based around economic
growth and stability for those reasons i
think the disruption to sort of global
economic markets um all of the kind of
insecurity that's been inspired by this
invasion is not something that um
the president she and his regime were
thrilled about um but certainly i think
you know as as has just been made clear
there's no room for naivety here i think
he is always acting within his own
interests um and it's not necessarily a
sort of values-driven approach which we
in the west might um might sort of like
to anticipate i think we have to accept
that there are some degrees of
meaningful cooperation emerging between
china and russia i think we have slept
walked on a bunch of those and we need
to be incredibly attuned to them
there has just recently been a new kind
of international relations packed
between the two leaders but that said
china does fundamentally recognize there
are some areas of the international
community and the world order that
continues to wish to play in when it
suits their interests
okay alistair burt you spent you've
probably spent quite a lot of time in
rooms with people from both
uh countries
would china be a friend in this
situation
it's the wrong word uh china has
interests uh and china has interests in
a stable
stable world for its economic
advancement it has made so much in the
last 20 30 years all over the world it's
belton road program economic development
stability is essential for that if that
is disrupted and people are now talking
about the impact of of
food disruption
the wheat harvest being affected people
not getting enough food anything that
affects the stability that china has
depended on will cause them difficulty i
think they've been surprised at the
reaction of the west as well and that
will give them another reason to try and
find some way to minimize the damage
that's being done but i think the
friendship is is perhaps not the right
word also remember as we talk in vienna
at the moment
russia
china the united kingdom
are all working together in relation to
a new
nuclear deal with iran and they are
sitting down and having to work together
with all this going on as well and i
make that point because where interests
coincide and they're trying to get
get a new deal in very difficult
circumstances people can work together
but no one should be guided by any sense
of friendship here dave mccormack i
think dave you're in uh doncaster dave
what do you think about this prospect of
uh china
being able to help to broker some kind
of peace
yeah uh to me china is the only nation
capable of stopping putin on top of
increased western sanctions
i'll give you an analogy to the current
war
putin is the school bully terrorizing
the smaller kid ukraine
the rest of the playground need to
persuade a stronger nation to intervene
to counteract him
this is not just nato but china
the west needs to persuade china that
its gdp and economy is heavily reliant
on western trade
nearly 14 percent of uk imports are from
china usa has 20 from china
china really needs to make a choice to
either continue exporting to the west or
deal with russia whom the rest of the
world has alienated if china sides with
the west the russian economy would
collapse all right dave thank you very
much and uh you're getting a lot of
support right there behind you
bill braudo
china the answer
well let's look at the story so um
putin waited until the end of the
olympics in china
before he invaded ukraine why did he do
that because he didn't want to make his
friend ji ji ping
look bad and mess up his his big
spectacle
i don't think there's any chance in a
thousand years that china is going to
intervene to do anything here china sees
this as an opportunity
as as as the west surrounds russia and
economically isolates russia
china sees this as a great way for
russia to go
to a lender of last resort and saying to
say to the
chinese we need money and the chinese
will be licking their lips
and saying yeah you can borrow some
money um on a credit card terms
and and why don't you throw in this
pipeline and throw in this oil field and
throw in this and that this is this is
like the biggest opportunity for china
to take what they want
from russia
okay
as i say on other shows to be continued
i don't suppose this is the last time
we're going to be talking about this
but that's all we have time for this
evening so just remain for me to say
thank you to our panelists here in the
studio
bill browder sophia gaston alastair
burke sacha havlicek
of course it's you at home at the center
of this conversation if you'd like to be
part of the program next time get in
touch by emailing the great debate at
sky dot uk
and for now thank you as always to the
wall to our viewers panel
very thoughtful contributions tonight
and especially thank you to those from a
russian and ukrainian
background
for you at home
keep talking and we'll see you again at
the same time next week for the great
debate
[Music]
[Music]
foreign